actually I asked Mel to present uh this
award to me for a reason because when I
couldn't get sober he told me not to
give up hope and he urged me to find my
faith didn't have to be his or anyone
else's as long as it was rooted in
forgiveness and I couldn't get hired so
he cast me in the lead of a movie that
was actually developed for him and he
kept a roof over my head and he kept
food on the table and most importantly
he said that if I accepted
responsibility for my wrongdoings and if
I embraced that part of my soul it was
ugly hugging the cactus he calls it
he said that if I hug the cactus long
enough I'd become a man of some humility
and that my life would take on a new
meaning and I did and it worked all he
asked in return was that someday I
helped the next guy in some small way
it's reasonable to assume that at the
time he didn't imagine the next guy
would be him
or that someday was tonight